It should be alright! There it goes! Aww,
actually that’s quite
spectacular at the end.
And in my second-year, I think I love boron
far too much I think,
‘cause I talk about it too much.
You love boron?
I love boron! No, I used to do lots of chemistry
with boron, I
kind of moved away a little bit from boron
now but I really
like it.
Boron is an interesting element. It is one
of the few that I
have actually made myself when I was at school.
Boron sits on top of the group 13. Its atomic
number is 5, so
it is a metalloid, so elemental boron is a
metalloid which
basically means that it has some of the properties
of a non
metal and some of the properties of a metal.
I mixed an oxide of boron with magnesium,
heated it up and
then, it is a really dramatic reaction when
you add water at
the end to try and destroy the magnesium boride
that has
formed because you get puffs of gas coming
off which burst
into flames rather like little anti-aircraft
guns. But boron itself
was rather disappointing; it’s a sort of
brown powder.
I mean there is a more of a powdery brown
boron, there are
several crystalline sort of types of alatropes
of boron. There is
one actually that is really, really hard,
so the black crystalline
boron is actually very, very hard. It’s
just below diamond on
Mohs scale of hardness, so I believe. And
actually in America,
there is a town called Boron. It’s in California,
it’s got a
population of around 2000 which actually was
set up around
the world’s biggest borax mine which is
in California.
Well it used to be transported on trains of
mules and the
company that produced it used to have as their
trademark a
train of 20 mules sort of going along.
Of great interest to us chemists, well over
the last sort of 50,
maybe sort of 60-70 years, have been the boron
hydrides or
borades. So boron hydrides are basically clusters
of borons
with hydrogens around them. And one of particular
use and
interest in the 50s was one called pentaborane,
which
basically: penta, five, it’s got five borons
in it. And
Pentaborate was investigated during the cold
war or in the
early part of the cold war as being a rocket
fuel. It actually
burns with a green flame. They actually called
it the ‘green
dragon’ because it burns with a very, very
hot green flame
and also because it is pretty toxic, which
I can actually show
you if I … It is probably not going to be
spectacular.
And boron complexes or borax compounds are
used in a
variety of things. It is not a particularly
expensive material. It
is used in washing powder, particularly perborate
which when
you heat it up in the washing machine when
the water gets to
60 degrees centigrade it turns into hydrogen
peroxide which
can then bleach the clothes and this is why
the famous
washing powder is called Persil, because the
‘per’ stands for
perborate and the ‘sil’ stands for silicate
so it is really a
mixture of perborate and silicate.
Ok so this isn’t pentaborane because pentaborane
spontaneously combusts in the air. This is
just benzene
boronic acid. It’s an organic compound with
some boron in it.
So hopefully we can see, we should be able
to see, if I can
get some at the end of my spatula, that it
should be able to
burn with some sort of green flame. Hey, there
it is. You can
also see a bit of yellow which is the organic
bit going as well.
It should be alright! There it goes! Aww,
actually that was
quite spectacular at the end. Ok.